[Musik]
suchen zu beginnen vielen Dank Opa sehr
geehrter Herr Generalstabschef sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Medien
Liebe Zuseherinnen und Zuseher im
Livestream ich darf Sie alle ganz
herzlich hier begrüßen im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
zu unserem zweiten bilanz-schuhe fix das
ist ja ein neues Format viele von ihnen
waren ja das letzte Mal dabei also im
April damit gestartet haben Bilanz zu
ziehen und das wollen wir gemeinsam
heute tun eine Bilanz nämlich über das
erste halbe Jahr 2023 um Ihnen einen
überblicke zu geben wo und wie zum einen
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
eingesetzt sind wo sie üben
aber auch wo wir mit unserer Mission
vorwärts wo wir bei unserem Aufbauplan
2032 plus stehen das ist eine Bilanz die
verdeutlicht dass wir als Bundesheer in
diesem ersten Halbjahr vor sehr großen
Herausforderungen gestanden sind bzw
noch stehen die es zu bewältigen galt
bzw gilt wenn ich nur beispielsweise an
den erdbebeneinsatz in der Türkei denke
an die Einsätze in den
überflutungsgebieten in Kärnten der
Steiermark aber auch bei unseren
Nachbarn in Slowenien auf diese
Einsatzzahlen wird dann der Chef des
generalstaubsauger im Anschluss Neon
ganz konkret auch eingehen es ist aber
jedenfalls auch eine Bilanz sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die zeigt dass unsere
Mission vorwärts im folgenange ist sei
es was die Beschaffungen anbelangt was
die Bauvorhaben anbelangt aber auch eben
die Übungen die vermehrt den großen
Ausmaßen wieder stattfinden
wie Sie wissen stehen wir
alle Organisationen alle Unternehmen
auch der öffentliche Dienst vor einer
sehr großen Herausforderung was die
Personalsituation anbelangt die
Herausforderung eben als attraktiver
Arbeitgeber Dienstgeber gesehen zu
werden und entsprechend qualifiziertes
Personal auch zu finden auch in diesem
Bereich haben wir einiges an erfolgen
bereits vorzuweisen und zu feiern wir
haben auf der einen Seite mit dem ersten
April einen Meilenstein im Personalwesen
gesetzt mit dem freiwilligen
Grundwehrdienst für Frauen da haben wir
tatsächlich ein neues Kapitel
aufgeschlagen wir haben es geschafft die
einstiegswürde für in das Bundesheer für
Frauen zu senken Sie wissen bis dato war
sehr notwendig beim Heerespersonalamt in
Wels gleich einmal den vollen
Leistungstest doch durchzuführen jetzt
haben wir die Gleichstellung mit den
männlichen Kollegen mit einer Stellung
einer unserer Sex
das erfreuliche ist dass wir bereits 144
freiwilligen Meldungen von Frauen
bekommen haben es sind bereits Frauen
eingerückt 17 sind es bis Jahresende
werden dann noch weitere 41 Soldatinnen
einrücken folgen was wir noch versuchen
versucht haben ist dass immer dann wenn
Betriebsschließungen in größerem Ausmaß
wahrzunehmen sind wie das zum Beispiel
bei kika leider der Fall war oder auch
bei Opel jetzt heißt das ja der stillant
ist Werk in Aspern dann gehen wir ganz
offensichtlich sie auf die Bediensteten
zu und machen Sie auf eine neue Chance
die wir als Bundesheer zu bieten haben
aufmerksam und auch da haben wir einen
Erfolg aufzuweisen durch diese
Initiative des offenen Zugehen auf
diejenigen haben sich bereits 31
Bewerber Bewerberinnen gemeldet und es
ist bereits mit 19 Personen der
Aufnahmeprozess gestartet worden auch
für diejenigen in Aspern Form als das
Opel Werk werden wir Informationen zur
Verfügung stellen aber nicht nur das
sondern wir werden auch direkt dort vor
Ort sein um mit dem Bediensteten über
die vielfältigen Möglichkeiten die wir
beim Heer anbieten können zu sprechen
und hoffentlich eben neues Personal auch
gewinnen zu können weil wir zahlreiche
eben Pensionierungen und Abgänge
auszugleichen haben um Ihnen da eine
Zahl zu nennen wir benötigen in den
nächsten Jahren ca 1000 neue Soldatinnen
Soldaten
Zivilbedienstete pro Jahr das ist eine
sehr große Anzahl aber wir sehen das
sehr viele der Bemühungen neben
natürlich der großen Offensive auch der
medialen bereits gewirkt haben für das
erste Halbjahr können wir tatsächlich
erfreuliche Zahlen präsentieren mit dem
heutigen Stichtag haben wir
1233 Soldatinnen und Soldaten sowie
Zivilbedienstete
aufnehmen können wenn man das jetzt
vergleicht mit der Zahl für das gesamte
Jahr
2022 wo das 1449 waren dann sieht man
unsere Bemühungen haben gewirkt wir
haben in einem Halbjahr bei nahe so viel
wie das vorige ganze Jahr erreicht sie
sehen die Maßnahmen beginnen zu wirken
aber eines muss man auch ganz offen
sagen wir sind nicht am Ende angelangt
besonders eben auch wenn es darum geht
mehr Frauen für den Beruf der Soldatin
zu motivieren all diese
personaloffensiven sind eines mit
Sicherheit ein Marathon und kein Sprint
ein Marathon auf dem wir einen sehr
langen Atem beweisen müssen unser Bestes
geben werden um gemeinsam diese
Herausforderung auch bewältigen zu
können
jetzt komme ich noch zu den
Beschaffungen was insbesondere den
Aufbauplan 2032 Plus im Rahmen unserer
Mission vorwärts anbelangt sie wissen ja
wir müssen vieles beschaffen umsetzen
und auch vieles beschleunigen wenn ich
nur an unsere neuen Uniformen denke das
sind wir so weit dass mittlerweile 18
Verbände mit der neuen tanuniform
ausgestattet sind wir werden sehr viel
früher um Jahre früher fertig sein mit
der Vollausstattung nämlich schon Ende
2026 und es freut mich dass wir auch
präsentieren können wie viele der
Gerätschaften und Fahrzeuge bereits in
diesem Halbjahr 2023 der Truppe
übergeben werden konnten ich nenne hier
exemplarisch einige große Zuläufe
beginnen von dem Pandur Evo 7 die
alleine in diesem Halbjahr wieder dazu
gekommen sind die neuen Hubschrauber
Leonardo da sind mittlerweile vier
gelandet es sind zwei Tablet im ersten
Halbjahr von der Modernisierung zurück
umgekehrt sechs zusätzliche Verbände wie
gesagt die angesprochenen gesamt 18 sind
mit dem neuen Tarnanzug ausgestattet 60
Pickup L200 ferngesteuerte löschroboter
für das ABC Abwehrzentrum die militis
ausgestattet worden mit den neuen
Sturmgewehren und sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich müsste dann noch so lange
sprechen dass daher generalstoffchef
dann nicht mehr zu den konkreten Zahlen
dann auch kommt wir werden Ihnen das
sehr gerne auch nachliefern was es aber
zeigt dass wichtig ist und sie wissen ja
dass die Truppe lange nicht daran
geglaubt hat verständlicherweise dass
diese Mission auch tatsächlich umgesetzt
wird und erst daran glaubt wenn das
Gerät im Kasernenhof steht bzw im Hangar
steht das haben wir geschafft wir haben
allein in diesem Halbjahr neu Verträge
abgeschlossen mit einem Gesamtvolumen
von 390 Millionen Euro in diesen
Verträgen sind zum Beispiel 125 Stück
irgendwie LKWs 850 Stück LKWs
Rheinmetall in verschiedensten
Ausführungen Munition auch keine Frage
und kleinere Fahrzeuge das heißt unser
Aufbauplan betrifft nicht nur unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten moderne
Arbeitsgeräte die zu beschaffen sind wir
müssen uns auch darum kümmern dass bevor
der Einsatz beginnt auch das Zuhause die
Unterkünfte passen und auch in dem
Bereich der Investitionen in den
Kasernen die tatsächlich nicht so sind
in manchen Bereichen wie wir uns das
wünschen würden haben wir kräftig
investiert und werden das auch weiterhin
tun alleine 2023 Bauvorhaben in der Höhe
von 70 Millionen Euro gestartet worden
ein Beispiel die Unterkunft und
Wirtschaftsgebäude der Wiener Neustädter
Burg 42 Millionen Euro ein weiteres neu
saniertes Mannschaftsgebäude in
allensteig Fliegerhorst promofsky wo ja
24 der neuen Hubschrauber Station
dann heißt das nur für diesen neuen
Hubschrauber neue Infrastruktur im Wert
von 28 Millionen Euro investiert werden
wird das sind alles Projekte die jetzt
nur beispielhaft dafür stehen für die
enormen Bauvorhaben die wir im Rahmen
unseres aufbauplanes durchführen werden
wir haben nicht nur zu bauen begonnen im
ersten Halbjahr 2023 haben wir auch
schon Gebäude eben für die Truppe
freigegeben in lange leben dort ist
immer etwas was neu gebaut wird und
fertiggestellt wurde war die abronhalle
in der standschützenkaserne in
Innsbrucker modernisiertes
Mannschaftsgebäude und so weiter sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sie sehen unser
Aufbauplan der läuft auf Hochtouren die
Investitionen in die Infrastruktur
werden umgesetzt die Truppe erhält
laufend neues Gerät und diesen Weg
wollen wir weitergehen denn eines ist
klar diese Mission vor wir eines ist
klar diese Mission vorwärts die wir beim
letzten Nationalfeiertag ausgerufen
haben das ist nicht nur ein SL sondern
das ist für uns ein Auftrag ein Auftrag
unseren Soldatinnen und Soldaten das
beste Umfeld die beste Ausrüstung zur
Verfügung zu stellen der polizeilichen
Assistenzeinsatz an der Grenze in den
Bundesländern Burgenland Steiermark
Kärnten und Tirol zum Zwecke der
Bekämpfung der illegalen Migration und
wir haben in der ersten Jahreshälfte und
1.140 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
diesbezüglich im Einsatz gehabt und es
ist uns durch intensives zusammenwirken
und vor allem sehr kooperatives
Zusammenwirken zwischen dem
Innenministerium der den
Landespolizeidirektionen und den
einsatzführenden militärkommanden
gelungen
dieser Einsatzzahlen zu reduzieren so
dass wir ab Juli rund 720 Einsatz
Soldatinnen und Soldaten
nunmehr abstellen müssen das hat einen
großen Vorteil für uns insofern als das
wir die Anzahl der Grundwehrdiener die
diese assistenzleistung Leisten deutlich
reduzieren konnten warum ist das so
wichtig das ist deswegen der Fall weil
wir
damit in der Lage sind unsere
Grundwehrdiener wieder vermehrt in eine
waffengattungsbezogene militärische
Ausbildung zu führen zum Zwecke der
militärischen Landesverteidigung das
dient zur Erhöhung der
Einsatzbereitschaft auf der einen Seite
und vor allem aber auch dazu dass wieder
mehr Soldaten sich freiwillig für die
Miliz verpflichten ein ganz ein
wichtiger Aspekt wenn es um die
Einsatzbereitschaft des Bundesheeres
geht
wir führen aber auch weiterhin
sicherheitspolizeiliche
assistenzleistung in Wien und zwar mit
für die Landespolizeidirektion Wien zum
Schutz von
völkerrechtssubjekten Objekten also 21
Botschaften etc werden durch das
Bundesheer entsprechend bewacht und
geschützt es sind dafür rund 100
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und in diesem
Fall
Kaderpersonal Berufssoldaten und milit-
zusammengefasst haben wir also im
Inlandseinsatz derzeit und 820
Soldatinnen und Soldaten was den
sicherheitspolizeilichenassistentensatz
betrifft
da Katastrophen gibt es immer wieder und
überall natürlich auch in Österreich und
das Bundesheer steht stets bereit hier
entsprechend zu unterstützen wir haben
heuer bereits mehrere diesbezügliche
Assistenz Einsätze leisten müssen und
können und dürfen wir hatten stark
Schneefälle sozusagen kaum vorstellbar
bei den derzeitigen Temperaturen wir
haben aber auch Personen suchen
durchgeführt
und auch das letzte das Wochenende das
Hochwasser des letzten Monats
entsprechend
unterstützt bei der Bewältigung der
Folgen dieser Katastrophe
insgesamt ist es so dass insbesondere
hier in Kärnten Steiermark und im
Burgenland
mehrere
hundert Soldatinnen und Soldaten und 400
zum Zwecke der Bekämpfung der
Hochwasserkatastrophe im Einsatz standen
und nach wie vor stehen
hinzu kommt dass wir im Kärnten vor
allem zwei bundesheerhubschrauber ein
S70 Black Hawk und eine ab 212 im
Einsatz hatten um entsprechende
Transporte durchzuführen wir haben dort
knapp 200 Flüge durchgeführt haben dort
263 Personen evakuiert und 19.000
Kilogramm hilfst und unterstützungsgüter
mit den Hubschraubern transportiert
hinzu kommt der Spezialisten des abc-
das Bundesheer ist darüber hinaus und
das ist heuer zum Glück noch so nicht
passiert aber im Vorjahr hatten wir
einen heftigen Waldbrand in Hirschwang
in der Lage entsprechende Unterstützung
für die zivilen Feuerwehren die
Freiwilligen Feuerwehren zu leisten ein
Schwergewicht zu bilden wenn es zu
Waldbränden in Österreich kommt
da
unterstützen uns insbesondere unsere
Hubschrauber der Black Hawk S70 die
August der Welt 212 aber auch der neue
Hubschrauber AW 169 und das
Flächenflugzeug pilatusporter 6 sind es
in der Lage hier unterstützend
entsprechend einzuwirken auf der einen
Seite durch
Transport von Wasser
zur direkten Brandbekämpfung oder zur
Auffüllung von
wasserreservens der Feuerwehr und
andererseits aber auch durch die Nutzung
von
Wärmebildkameras mit denen man dann
entsprechend glutenester
ausnehmen kann etc
wir haben also spezielle Löschfahrzeuge
der militärischen Feuerwehren
insbesondere der PC abwehrtruppe wir
haben aber auch auf den
Truppenübungsplätzen Feuerwehren
klarerweise die ist so hier zum Einsatz
gebracht werden können und für den Fall
dass es notwendig ist können wir so
rasch und umfangreich helfen nun zu den
Auslandseinsätzen die das Bundesheer
natürlich nach wie vor bestreitet und
das über Jahrzehnte bereits wir haben
1960 damit begonnen mit multinationalen
Friedenseinsätzen und mit der
internationalen humanitären und
Katastrophenhilfe
derzeit ist es so also der ersten
Jahreshälfte dass wir rund 1000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in insgesamt 16
Auslandsmissionen im Einsatz hatten das
Schwergewicht dieser Missionen ist nach
wie vor der Westbalkan mit der
NATO-Mission im Kosovo und der Mission
der Europäischen Union in Bosnien
wir leisten aber auch für die Feinden
Nationen im Libanon einen entsprechenden
logistischen Beitrag zwei
Einsätze im Ausland möchte ich besonders
hervorheben die vom Bundesministerin hat
das kurz angesprochen auf der einen
Seite unserer
einser-katastrophenhilfeeinsatz
anlässlich des türkischen Erdbebens
mit unserer katastrophenhilfseinheit
82 Personen sechs rettungshundetrupps
und mit 40 Tonnen Material unterwegs war
und dort immerhin und das ist wirklich
sehr
bedeutend neuen Menschen leben retten
konnte darunter zwei Kinder
der zweite Einsatz den ich ansprechen
möchte ist dass wir selbst bei unseren
Herausforderungen die wir während der
Hochwasserkatastrophe in dem letzten
Monat hatten auch Slowenien entsprechend
unterstützen konnten wo ja die
Katastrophe noch verheerende
Auswirkungen hatte und immerhin einen
S70 und eine 212 dort für mehrere Tage
im Einsatz bringen konnten die dort also
eine wertvolle Unterstützung leisten
konnten
etwas weniger im Vordergrund steht unser
entmündungsdienst der auch tagtäglich 24
Stunden am Tag theoretisch abrufbar im
Einsatz ist wir konnten in der ersten
Jahreshälfte 66 Pfund und
wahrnehmungsmeldungen entgegennehmen aus
der Bevölkerung die also auf
Kriegsmaterial hingewiesen hat und haben
insgesamt immerhin
21.500 Kilogramm
Kriegsmaterial sichergestellt und von
diesen 6000 Kilogramm auf den
ungsplätzen in großmittel und allen
Steig sicher gesprengt
interessant ist aber auf der anderen
Seite auch wieder nicht überraschend
dass die meisten Einsätze nämlich 281
alleine Niederösterreich zu absolvieren
war ein Relikt aus
längst vergangenen Zeiten da sieht man
wie lange es dauert bis hier tatsächlich
endlich einmal eine Ruhe diesbezüglich
ist
damit wir eine erfolgreiche
Einsatzführung durchführen können und
sie ist erfolgreich ich merke dass immer
wieder wenn ich im Ausland unsere
Kontingente Besuche und die Resonanz aus
der internationalen Gemeinschaft
erfahren darf
eine Voraussetzung dafür ist eine
gute Übungstätigkeit des Bundesheeres
und dank des Einsatzes unserer
Bundesministerin was unsere Budget und
unsere finanziellen Ressourcen betrifft
sind wir jetzt auch in der Lage deutlich
mehr zu üben und wir tun das auch mit
mehr und vor allem auch größeren Übungen
und wir haben heuer immerhin schon
folgende Übungen die Großübungen sind
durchgeführt zunächst die Übungsserie
Handwerk 2023 der vierten panzerinnen
mit 650 Soldatinnen und Soldaten und
immerhin 170 Kampf und
gefechtsfahrzeugen
dann eine Großübung der 7 jägerbrigade
mit rund 1600 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
dann die große Übung Steinfeld im
Steinfeld also im Raum Wiener Neustadt
der Theresianischen Militärakademie wo
immerhin 1.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
150 Fahrzeuge und 12 Schützenpanzer
unterwegs waren einschließlich eines
tschechischen Kompanie starken
übungskontingenz und dann haben wir eine
ausbildungsübung Serie Konstruktor heißt
die wir wo es darum geht Kader Personal
auf der untersten Ebene Druck-
Bundesheeres und sie übt im heurigen
Jahr insgesamt mit rund 160
übungsvorhaben das sind aber nur die
Übungen und nicht die
Ausbildungsmaßnahmen die sonst insgesamt
auch von der Miliz entsprechend
betrieben werden
zusammenfassend kann ich feststellen
dass wir uns auf einem sehr guten Weg
befinden dass die Ressourcen da sind
dass das Bundesheer auch entsprechend
beübt werden kann dass die
Einsatzbereitschaft entsprechend hoch
gehalten werden kann und damit auch die
Attraktivität des Bundesheeres
insbesondere für Grundwehrdiener aber
auch für das Kaderpersonal entsprechend
steigt und ich darf also hier
feststellen dass wir uns aus meiner
Sicht auf dem richtigen Weg befinden und
auch meinen Dank an unsere Frau
Bundesministerin im Namen des
österreichischen Bundesheeres
aussprechen dass wir auf einem
gemeinsamen Weg uns in die richtige
Richtung befinden für ein modernes
Bundesheer und insbesondere für den
Schutz der österreichischen Bevölkerung
danke schön
vielen Dank ich darf sie nun um Ihre
Fragen suchen
es finden laufend eben runden Stadt die
nächste wird im Oktober dann noch sein
und wir sind auf einem sehr guten Weg
wie auch in der Pressemeldung
angekündigt das Ziel muss eines sein
dass so wie bei der noch geltenden
Sicherheitsstrategie ein über alle
Parteigrenzen gehen der Beschluss dann
auch gefasst wird das ist unser aller
gemeinsames Ziel und da wird sehr
intensiv auch daran gearbeitet viel
wichtiger als einzelne Papiere sind ohne
Zweifel die Investitionen in unser
Bundesheer das ist das was Österreich
sicherer macht
vielen Dank
beginne bei Sky Shield wir haben
gemeinsam ja mit der Schweiz und im
Beisein des deutschen
Verteidigungsministers Kollegen
Pistorius die Absichtserklärung
unterschrieben der nächste Schritt wird
jetzt sein dass zu Beginn September eine
Konferenz der erdschiffs stattfindet wo
auch unser erdgeschäft Bromberger mit
dabei sein wird diese
Absichtserklärung gibt uns die
Möglichkeit in die Papiere eben in die
Unterlagen auch Einschau zu halten das
werden wir tun und dann wird man sehen
wie viel schon bis dato entschieden
worden ist bzw wie wir uns einbringen
können ein Beispiel zu nennen
Deutschland der Kollege hat jetzt
verkündigt verkündet dass sie arrows 3
eben beschaffen werden das ist ein ganz
besonderes System dass es möglich macht
der
Bedrohungen aus der Luft Raketen
ähnliches bereits in der Stratosphäre
auch abzufangen das ist doch ein System
das unglaublich teuer ist für einen
einzelnen Staat wohl auch zu
kostenintensiv zu beschaffen wäre und da
wird man eben sehen wie wir uns als
Österreich einbringen können schon zu
Beginn als wir die Erklärung abgegeben
haben haben wir gesagt wir können uns
eins vorstellen dass wir insbesondere
unserer sehr erfolgreiches
passives luftüberwachungssystem Gold
habe dann auch einbringen das machen wir
schon über entsprechende Einkommen bei
Einkommen mit der Deutschland und mit
der Schweiz aber konkreter es gibt es
dann eben wenn unser erdgeschäft die
Unterlagen auch einsehen durfte dazu ist
eben so ist die Schweiz auch gemacht hat
diese
Beitrittserklärung diese Erklärung
notwendig um das tun zu können
was die Frage der Chats anbelangt wir
haben die entsprechenden Möglichkeiten
chattrainer zu besorgen die sind auch im
Ablaufplan 220 32
beinhaltet das heißt 12 Stück in jedem
Fall mit einer Option auf 12 weitere in
unserem Haus wird jetzt geprüft ob diese
Option auf 12 weitere unterteilt wird in
Drohnen sie wissen wir haben auch dann
und wendigkeiten zu investieren das Ziel
ist so wie genannt eben dass wir einen
Vertrag dann im Jahr 2024 unterschreiben
können
nächste Frage bitte
Entscheidung kommen im Sinne von
government mit einem anderen Land weil
dann nächstes Jahr gibt Verträge vor
einer eventuellen
ich beginne mit dem was dringender
notwendig ist nämlich die Nachfolge nach
der C130 nach unserer Herkules der
Sommer dauert ja noch bis zum 21
September bis dorthin werden wir eine
typenentscheidung bekannt geben und wie
damals eben schon gesagt auch den
entsprechenden Vertrag dann zu Beginn
2024 unterschreiben das ist das Ziel
aber sie haben etwas sehr Wichtiges
angesprochen die Frage für all unsere
Planungen und was allfällige Wahlen
anbelangt das war uns ein ganz wichtiges
Ziel dass wir im
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
einen Plan haben der über die
Legislaturperiode hinausgeht nämlich bis
zum Jahr 32 wir setzen das Plus deshalb
dazu weil er dann die Arbeit und die
Investitionen in das österreichische
Bundesheer nicht zu Ende sein dürfen
aber das heißt ein Beschluss ein Gesetz
das garantiert dass das Budget für das
österreichische
bundesheeranwachsen wird das heißt ein
rückgängig machen all dieser Dinge wird
sehr schwer möglich sein und das war uns
ganz besonders wichtig weil sich das
österreichische Bundesheer und die
Sicherheit nicht eignet für irgendwelche
Partei politischen Befindlichkeiten das
ist ein sehr wichtiger Schritt der uns
von vielen Staaten auch unterscheidet
und zu meinen einmal die Planbarkeit
auch gibt auf der anderen Seite auch dem
Steuerzahler der Steuerzahlerin
transparent größtmögliche gibt weil wir
haben ja dann jährlich auch mit einem
landesverteidigungsbericht den Parlament
dem Ausschuss zunächst und den Plenum
auch vorzulegen wie weit sind wir in
unserem Beschaffungen bereits
vorangeschritten wo müssen wir
nachjustieren im all diese Fragen die
auch zu Sky shit gestellt worden sind da
wird ja noch einiges auch zu adaptieren
sein und darüber auch dann entsprechend
das Parlament zu investieren das ist
sehr zu informieren das ist sehr viel an
investierten Geld von in Wahrheit uns
allen und das wichtigste ist da eben
ganz transparent zu sein und das ist
unser Ziel Transparenz auf der einen
Seite und Planbarkeit eben über die
Legislaturperiode hinaus auf der anderen
Seite
so wie wir
so wie wir das immer so wie wir das
immer auch angekündigt haben den
chat-trainer sehen wir später wie gesagt
wir haben diese Möglichkeiten jetzt dazu
durch das durch das Budget und sie haben
sehr angesprochen es sind ja einige
Fragen auch zu klären welche
Möglichkeiten da Zusammenarbeit gibt das
ist ja auch alles abzuwägen welche
Staaten haben das eine oder das andere
Modell bereits auch im Einsatz mit denen
man eben dann die genannten Abkommen
auch treffen kann aber wir sind im
Zeitplan so wie mit allen Dingen
eigentlich im Aufbau planen
das System unserer 15 Eurofighter lauft
bis zum Jahr 2035 vom technischen her
und ihm Aufbauplan sind stufenweise
entsprechende Investitionen man kann das
auch alles nachlesen bzw wir geben Ihnen
ja dann auch eine entsprechende
Information mit ist festgehalten dass in
der ersten Stufe die erste Stufe läuft
2022 bis 24 investiert wird in die nach
identifizierungsfähigkeit und in den
Selbstschutz und die weiteren Schritte
der nachzusetzen sind der Chef das
Generalstabs hat der Bundeswehr eine
entsprechende Information erhalten dass
es die Möglichkeit gebe Doppelsitzer
anzukaufen da sind wir eben gerade in
der entsprechenden Prüfung sobald diese
zu Ende ist werden wir dann informieren
darüber gibt es weitere Fragen
so wie ich von anbeginnern gesagt habe
das ist keine Reform und um ihrer selbst
willen sondern sie hat einen Zweck dass
wir eben all unserer Engagement in die
Truppe setzen und dort verschlanken und
Beschleunigen was möglich ist das haben
wir ja gemacht wenn sie nur allein die
Anzahl der obersten Einheiten Betrachten
von fünf auf drei reduziert das ist ein
laufender Prozess wo wir auch immer
wieder drauf kommen was es noch zu
optimieren gilt und sie haben Recht
einiges ist noch von den Bewertungen her
beim bmkurs das ist auch das zuständige
Bundesministerium ich bin mir sicher
dass wir da in sehr vielen Dingen und
das ist ja schon passiert auf einen
guten Konsens auch stoßen das Ziel wie
gesagt ist klar keiner der bedienste
darf auch nur irgendwie in irgendeiner
Art und Weise schlechter gestellt werden
das Ziel und der Fokus muss auf der
Stärkung eben der Truppe auch liegen und
dieser auf dieser Zielsetzung sind wir
unterwegs es ist ja auch eine laufende
Evaluierung die dann immer wieder
erfolgt nachzujustieren ist aber wir
sind auch hier auf einem sehr guten Weg
sieht man allein schon dass wir eben bei
den Beschaffungen durch diese durch
diese Reformierung schon
Beschleunigungen erreichen konnten ich
habe das Beispiel der Uniformen
angeführt aber ich könnte wahrscheinlich
noch einige mehr erzählen ich nehme mal
unsere Hubschrauber her den Leonardo
wenn Sie jetzt ein Auto kaufen und sie
unterschreiben den Vertrag dann ist es
nur über selten dass das
bienenjahresfrist geliefert wird bei
unseren Hubschraubern war so bei den
Leonardo das war ganz genau ein Jahr
nach der Vertragsunterschrift und dann
stand der erste auch schon da in dem
Fall in lange leben also darum geht es
vor allem auch die Abläufe eben zu
straffen gibt es noch eine letzte Frage
bitte
nehmen und was noch komisch ist das
können wir gerne nachliefern wir haben
es für die heutige Pressekonferenz
einmal für das Halbjahr jetzt gemacht
aber das geben wir Ihnen gerne mit wir
haben einen vorbereitet bezieht sich
aber glaube ich auch nur auf das
Halbjahr und wir geben Ihnen aber dann
selbstverständlich die gesamten Zahlen
es ist ja bekannt wie wie die Summen
ausschauen und was wir für heuer auch zu
investieren zu investieren hatten aber
ich glaube sie interessiert wie viel
steht tatsächlich schon an
insofern auch eine wichtige Frage weil
wir ja vorgesehen haben für dieses Jahr
ein Plus am Budget von 680 Millionen
Euro das ja am Ende des budgetjahres
auch abverbraucht sein muss wo wir dann
wieder in die neuen in den neuen
Verhandlungen starten und da ist das
Ziel dass diese 680 Millionen auch
verbraucht werden und wenn wir heute die
Halbjahresbilanz ziehen und ich Ihnen
die Zahl genannt habe alleine da alleine
der Verträge die wir bis dato und wie
gesagt wir sprechen von einem halben
Jahr eben abgeschlossen haben an neuen
Verträgen diese 390 Millionen Euro die
ich genannt habe dann sieht man wir sind
ja auf einem sehr guten Weg und das ist
wirklich sehr gut durchgeplant und diese
Beispiele die hier genannt worden sind
beziehen sich aufs erste Halbjahr wir
liefern dann einfach noch nach was
sozusagen an Gerät auch noch da war ich
habe einiges davon genannt die Liste
seine sehr Verlängerung
danke kommen und bei schließe hier mit
die Pressekonferenz danke schön
danke schön